Kim Kardashian gives her sister Courtney
a little advice on her wedding day
something she says she learned during
her I Do's to her now ex Kanye West I'd
like to announce to you for the very
first time Mr and Mrs Travis Barker
on Thursday fans got an intimate look
inside the couple's nuptials on their
Hulu special till death do us part
Courtney and Travis can you believe we
got married three times yep three times
it's a beautiful thing first an
unofficial ceremony in Las Vegas after
the Grammys in April 2022 you did a
practice run on the wedding
congratulations thank you hi Travis
it's Courtney
hi Travis taking Courtney to be my wife
cut it I'm crying I got a call to the
celebrity want to get married and they
didn't tell me what was they just said a
celebrity and we need else then in May
the two made it official with an
intimate courthouse wedding in Santa
Barbara because we were getting married
in Italy to make it legal we had to do
our paperwork our legal paperwork in the
United States in California
all right paperwork
official and finally the two flew across
the pond to exchange vows in Portofino
Italy where Kim offered up these words
of wisdom
[Music]
I walked so fast
of course fans of the Kardashians
remember the veil drama during Ken's
2014 ideas to Kanye West also in Italy
in Florence
I love this long huge Veil but it's the
only thing that would make me trip and
fall right on my face and it makes me so
nervous well Court had some Veil drama
of her own
[Music]
yeah Court couldn't have walked fast if
she wanted to you just gotta roll with
it Vale snafu aside the wedding was
perfect just like the couples love he
brought us a lot in your fairy tale and
there's really no love story like you
guys it's a movie it's the cutest you
guys are the best my family means
everything to me so honestly as close As
It Gets of course fans of the famous fam
will get to see more of court and trav's
love on season three of the Kardashians
when it premieres on Hulu May 25th the
episodes are more a little bit
documentary style and I think that you
have a real insight not only you know
what you see in the press or whatever
but what's really happening behind the
scenes before you would see little
Snippets of something and now I think
the episodes are um you know Fuller of
content that shows the whole story
[Music]
thank you